hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play simulator 2016
I feel like there's gonna be an
adventure into making fun of myself but
I'm frankly ok with that your goal is to
grow the 1 million subscribers with your
hot Tube channel oh no way that made me
laugh the game is not random based read
emails carefully press ok for more
details and remember if you reach the
zero dollars no let's play for you
sad face this was also made in the Ludum
dare game jam so I tried it out
basically you'll get emails for requests
to review games and then you you like
decide if it's close to an actual game
that's made which is gonna be
problematic for me because I don't know
the names of developers very well and I
don't actually know all that many games
very well because I don't play games for
funded ok anyway got my got my
overreacting in there so now that I have
that I can move on with the rest of the
let's play continue do react I'm just
gonna make fun of all the let's play
trips while I'm doing this ok plot a two
this is völva we're developing bloated
to check this mobile game want to review
us yeah because that's dota 2 and
Plouffe Pablo vaye gloat gloat clove a
oh god my subs are growing best
performing stuff on my channel oh boy
here stone please review this great here
stone strategy game from please 'red
okay that sounds about right even though
I seem to be playing civilization 5 god
damn that is an accurate representation
of how Betsy my desk is - is smoking of
course let's see
bitcoins your bitcoin farm generated
some money I don't have a bitcoin farm
is Bitcoin farm even worth it anymore I
didn't think it was people used to have
like 17 graphics cards in one computer
trying to farm bitcoins if you don't
know how to farm bitcoins don't even ask
it's too complicated well if only your
PC had two video cards well damn okay
thank you
splash of plans this is super Cal we're
developing splash of plans oh man
I'm pretty sure that's correct in clash
of clans and one of the hella was named
classic clans videos wow this channel is
doing just wonderfully younger scroll
Boogaloo hidden Elder Scrolls oblivion
Oh God
WP flames simulator game well I mean
with some mods oblivion and Skyrim
became very apt simulator games and all
just depended on what you wanted
simulate no see younger scrolled pug
live Ian devs are stupid they don't know
how to make games boring game not for
poor my god my sub base didn't change
okay you're so tired I did it front row
what is front row just want to do an
action game called front row on coop my
card Nami I feel like someone had a
stroke is everything that's wet with it
it was made in three days but hot day
does that cat have three eyes oh no that
cat just has two big eyes never mind I'm
guessing that's contra by Konami and I'm
pretty sure they made that I didn't know
they made a new one but hey that's
pretty cool I guess
got lots of subs my soups are grubbing
I'll get 2 1 million on hot tube real
quick
working bread spell mate games working
bread wonderful adventure trial I don't
know who is that I am bread screw you
I'm not playing that oh this is bony I
just don't want to rage my brain out
mortar lands Borderlands sexy FPS mortar
land from beer box
fear fear box yes I'll play that I
actually don't really I've never
actually finished a Borderlands game
like in my entire life I've never
managed to finish one bomb or watch
overwatch J Sola blooms who's a solo
bloom no bomber watch devs are stupid ok
good glad I got a correctly silent peel
Konami hey that's not cool because they
that's stupid they're not doing it
anymore I'll do it
oh geez so scary I love my reactions on
this one good such a great content for
your channel I feel like I feel like I
should be ashamed of what's going on
here but kind of like and I'll better
get to a million oh man
blast Romania nin spend Oh Adventure
what the hell is that
what's blaster mania splatoon No
you're too tired to play is no sublease
didn't okay cool I guess
demon calls Oh demon souls is not as
good as Dark Souls but I think that's
right yeah sure whatever I'll do it I
played a lot of blood-borne by the way I
love blood-borne I still need to play
the new DLC I've been watching the game
grumps played man it's terrible at it
like I'm one to talk but watching Aaron
who boy he's the master of the r-1 spam
oh man no intricacy in his gameplay at
all I'm sorry Aaron I don't mean to
criticize but god damn you need to learn
some new moves
let's see coma oh yeah the horror
frictional games and it's got that one
right I wish this was how you like
YouTube actually worked why do I have a
hundred thousand subscriber play button
over on the right I only have three
thousand subs ear poured over your ports
never mind pass car simulator all right
sure I've never played a racing game in
my life no that's a lot like Gran
Turismo on the on the PlayStation 2 I
play that had a lot I love that game you
look bad go to sleep anyway go finally I
made more money than I lost I don't know
what I'm spending this is do deep duty
pie okay alright buddy he was born he
was Christ
I'm sorry
oh my god I love this
your girlfriend is hot when did I get a
girlfriend exactly your girlfriend
accidentally showed up in your stream
wearing lingerie yes thank you imaginary
girlfriend you're the best
no boy it's see monkey strong nin spend
oh I'm guessing that's donkey donkey
kong is it an action or is it an
adventure as two out of three is correct
pretty close
okay Tom henze inter fell Tom Clancy
Splinter Cell good lord pop star games
rock star was that rock star it is an
action you know that's a first-person
shooter so I don't think that's correct
not Chaka Khan bro you dick oh he Sports
Olympics champion retires at age of 23
he was old dam spammers okay bobcat
games glance plants vs. zombies yeah I
guess boertie
I lost mm I'm so sad this is hard okay
I'm gonna speed through this cow
simulator Oh paradox yeah I don't know
what that is Park more ham Oh bullsh
portal portal portal that's Mike
Morhaime push portal Hulse portal Wolf's
portal portal pulse portal pulse
Barnabas portal pull startled / Spartan
pulse portal pulse portal pulse portal
pull portal pulse portal pulls portal
No okay good yes
Oh God
hot tube suspended my channel jeez
that's pretty harsh lineage Oh lineage
okay whinnies - okay I got I got I got I
got I got it yeah yeah
Rockstar Games Max Payne yeah buzz if
the first-person shooter by action II I
guess nor nor park cartoon just had an
episode of how you big audience boost
yeah I'm duty by now
oh no this is Samantha apparently the
name of my girlfriend if you won't stop
playing these stupid games I'll leave
you no time for you have a sub trade to
keep going yes priorities dude okay I
think I'm almost there almost there
almost there EA games no miss off hatch
frogs
action games watchdogs yeah that's frogs
watchdogs god this is so stupid
funk one was funk oh god damn it
oh god I was in the clear
yes God
Oh what Oh God I just want to finish oh
so stupid yes yes okay yes oh god
finally oh god I'm the best hot tuber in
the world that took four frickin ever
and was really annoying it was plenty of
first and that got really annoying so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm sorry the youtubers that I made fun
of while is playing this game and thank
you again for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video